Now on to the topics of the day, we want to clarify some things and multiple questions
come in.
And these things, I really feel like they need to be clarified.
So one of the things that's clarified ozone, I spoke about ozone last week and one of
the patients said it felt like I was kind of downplayed the benefits of ozone in the
cancer therapy.
And I wanted to clarify that a little bit.
So multiple ways to get ozone into the system, and that is the key.
So can ozone be beneficial to kill cancer?
Yes, the struggle with it is, is that ozone by its very nature is very unstable.
So even if we inject it into our blood, the chance of it getting to my cancer site is
minimal, or the chance of getting to my cancer site is not very high.
So that's my struggle with ozone.
Now if you have, if the other way to get ozone is infiltration through putting it into a
bag and then doing it rectally.
So rectal ozone is a very good way to get it into your system.
It goes through the bloodstream there, but still as it gets into the bloodstream and travels
through the blood to get to my cancer, the chance of it being stable until it getting into
the capillary bed and then into the tissue and getting to my cancer is very slim.
Now the difference is if I have rectal or colon cancer, ozone is perfect, right?
So different types of cancer, ozone is going to be a great choice.
So one of the patients who want to be to clarify, this has rectal cancer or colon cancer
and they were using rectal ozone and I had told them, it's great, that's a great therapy,
but then they heard me kind of dis-ozoned last week and like they were confused.
So it depends on the type of cancer.
So if you're getting, if I have breast cancer and I'm going to do rectal ozone or ozone
through the bloodstream is what's the chance of it getting to my breast cancer, probably
it's pretty slim, but if I have colon cancer and I do a rectal ozone source, that's
a great tool.
So it gets back to, there's different therapies that have greater benefits for different types
of cancer.
So you've heard me say, okay, what besides the rife would be good for my cancer?
Well it depends on the cancer.
If I have liver cancer, my first choice for a secondary therapy would be the PEMF or
the hyperthermia.
If I have breast cancer, my first choice for secondary therapy would be the hyperthermia and then
maybe the PEMF.
If I have prostate cancer, hyperthermia would it be on that list, it'd be the PEMF.
So it depends on the type of cancer that you're dealing with, is that therapy, a real viable
therapy.
So if you have endless pockets, you could try everything to do everything and that might be
a good choice, however, everything takes a lot of time too.
So maybe that's not the best use of our time as well.
So always good, if you hear me say something on this and it's not pertain to your cancer,
you want some clarification, just email, make sure you put in that email header, something
that relates to zoom so that we catch it.
Remember, please don't email a bunch of questions through email, your email will most likely get
buried, if you have questions call the office or put on the email header on the subject
line, zoom question, so it gets seed, we literally get 100 to 200 emails a day.
So it will chance to be seeded, it can be slim.
So I don't want you to think that we're ignoring you.
Also Facebook is the form that you need to use to get your questions answered.
If it's a more of a more person later than make sure you call and schedule a time to
talk to myself or Angie or Michelle and we'll get those questions answered.
The other clarification is about Facebook feeds, somebody called today or yesterday or something
that said, I'm really concerned because I posted a question on the Connors Clinic Patients
Only page and it came up in my news feed.
Okay, so understand the way Facebook works, any groups that you belong to and the Connors
Clinic Patients Only page is a group.
If you post something to that group or somebody else post something to that group it will come
up in your news feed.
Now, because it comes up in your news feed does not mean it comes up to the public.
So don't confuse that and I understand it can be extremely confusing.
Oh my goodness, this is just a regular news feed that I'm looking at and my post came up
in there.
Oh my goodness, can everybody see that question that I asked?
It's kind of embarrassing.
I don't want the world to see that, no, they cannot see that.
Many people in that group can see that but your posts in a group will come up in your
feed.
It does not mean that it goes to the general public nor can any of other your friends see
it.
Nobody else in the world can see it except those that are in the Connors Clinic group.
So I know it's misleading because oh my goodness, it came in that feed but nobody else can
see it.
So make sure that you're clear about that.
So feel secure about that.
Also another little clarification about Facebook, for the most part, we are only allowing patients
on our Facebook group page.
We do.
Sometimes if there is some, if the patient has an advocate that is doing most of their communication
with the clinic for the patient, many times if the patient is very ill, their husband is doing
most of the communication or vice versa, they are allowed on the group.
But for the most part, even spouses were trying to not allow on the group unless they are the
patient advocate and certainly friends on patients.
And I know many of you have have suggested your friends to get on the Connors Clinic patients
only group page and I have denied the request.
So I don't think I mean need, but this is a privilege for patients only not for your friends
and such.
So just so you know, this is supposed to be a private group just for you guys.
So that's why we're trying to keep it.
Another clarification about rife use and foot baths, we get questions on a weekly basis
about the use of the rife and using other programs, okay.
So make this perfectly clear, the rife should be your first go to for everything.
Now I do not believe the rife is a panacea for every disease known to man, but it should
be your first go to.
I have an earache run the ear infection program, I have you know, use your use wisdom if you
broke your arm, don't try to run a program of the rife to heal your heart, but it should
be a go to program, I have a rash, I should run the inflammation program or find a program
that may be fitting, there's poison ivy, I think, programs on the rife.
So try to use the rife as a tool to help with any of your ills or any of your problems without
becoming a crazy hypochondriac that's that your husband divorces you because you're sitting
in front of the rife all the time, but it should be your first go to tool.
You can't hurt yourself running any programs on the rife.
So use them, clarification about the foot baths, make sure if you're using the foot bath
apparatus, you are switching, follow the instructions in your manual, flip the switch to bath and run
only ion pro wave programs with your foot bath, do not run other programs with your foot bath.
There are programs to be run with the ball, that's 99% of the programs on your rife.
And then there's a folder that says ion pro wave, those are the programs that you can run
with your foot bath.
Now many of you I have put an ion pro wave program that I want you to run in your folder, many
of you I have it, but the ones that have that in your folder then run that program.
So just be clear about that, look up your instructions, every one of you is given a rife
manual spiral bound kind of thing, and just look that up if you're if you're unclear about
that, if you have to call the clinic, you can go ahead and do so.
The rife function, we had a question come in that I missed, sorry, you know who you are,
the function of the rife, what does it do, you know, is it if it's killing bacteria things,
is it a killing by old cells, boy, we could have a couple hour discussion on the different theories
on how rife frequency works. There's multiple theories on how it works, I do cover this in some of my
videos that are on our website on rife theory, but just real clearly, is it damaged by old cells,
if I'm running a program, I do not believe there's any damage to your normal cells.
If I'm running the liver frequency cell program and it's running through normal liver frequencies,
it's helping bring residents to my liver cells and it's going to help my liver cells function better.
Rife believed that running a frequency of a cancer and his whole thing was trying to
tune in to that frequency of the cancer, if he could hit that cancer with its own frequency,
he would cause lysis of that cell, and that's with how he believed he had success with cancer patients
is that there was cell lysis. Now, I do believe that that may occur, but I don't believe that that
usually occurs. If you do hit a cancer frequency with its own, cancer cell with its own frequency,
remember, a cancer cell is your human body cell, so if you have breast cancer, it is a breast cell
that is in a rapid replication phase. One of the beliefs of rife, and I do believe that this does
take place many times, is that when you hit the breast cancer cell with its own frequency,
a breast frequency, a breast cell frequency, you bring back normal residents to the cell and the
cell stops rapidly replicating. That's why you don't always get shrinkage of the tumor.
So remember, what a cancer is, cancer is cells that are in a rapid replication phase. Well,
therefore, over time, there's a lot more cells. That's what a tumor is. So a tumor is cells that are
replicating. Therefore, they're getting more of them and they're getting larger. And then with cancer,
they're not going through normal apoptosis. So you're getting a mass that's getting bigger and bigger
and bigger. And I've told you a hundred times that our goal is not to make the mass go away. That
would be wonderful. We just want it to stop growing. Because if it stops getting bigger,
then we know it's not replicating. So if we can stop its replication, this rapid replication,
it stops, quote unquote, being cancer. So it fell off the definition of cancer since the definition
of cancer is rapidly replicating cells. So if we can get it to stop replicating, then we win.
So that's the goal of this altogether. So one of the theories of rife is that if you hit a
cancer cell with its own frequency, liver cancer or breast cancer, and you can bring residents back
to that cell and it starts acting like a normal breast cell or liver cell again, it stops replicating.
That doesn't mean the mass is going to disappear. So you have to get it out of your head that
this mass in my breast may never go away. And that's okay. We just got to get it to stop growing.
So that's part of the function of the rife with cancer. No, there's at least two dozen other theories
that all are viable and they probably are all applicable with how frequency medicine works with cancer.
So now nothing is going to work beyond God's desire for it to work in your life. So we are dealing with
that as well. So we have to deal with what the sovereignty of God has planned for the days of my life
with this, but we're supposed to be doing our part. So the rife is not a magic tool. It's not going
to be a cure all for everything all the time, but it's going to be a great tool for us.
And then lastly, before we open it up to questions, I want to clarify some things about the IVG test.
Now remember what the IVG test is measuring. It's measuring free cell DNA. It is that free cell
DNA. It's measured tumor markers on the circulating tumor cells. So out of that it's measured
are these tumor markers. The tumor suppressor cells are those percentage of those tumor suppressor
cells that are turned out or turned off. And the tumor oncogenes, whether they're turned out or turned
off, I mean the tumor suppressor genes, not tumor suppressor cells. So understand from when you look
at the DNA of a cell, you have all these different DNA that you could look at. Now there are tumor
suppressor genes. And there are tumor oncogenes. So an oncogen if it is, quote unquote, turned on,
then it can stimulate a cancer production. It can stimulate growth. It can stimulate replication.
Now, tumor suppressor genes, if they're not turned on, then it will lack suppressing the
oncogenes, kind of confusing, but tumor suppressor genes suppress replication, tumor suppressor
genes decrease replication. That's why if I have defects in numerous tumor suppressor gene pathways
by risk for cancer can go up and my ability to suppress cancer goes down. So there's two different
things. When we look at your genetics, we're looking at your tumor suppressor genes, and we're looking
at do I have defects on those tumor suppressor genes? And I could have, let's pretend I have perfect
genes, and I have no defects on my tumor suppressor genes. Does that mean I will never get cancer?
No, because getting cancer has nothing to do with tumor suppressor genes per se. It has to do with
toxins. It has to do with things that got into my cell. It has to do with my immune system response.
And yes, does it have something to do with tumor suppressor genes? Sure. If my tumor suppressor
genes don't have any defects on them, and they are turned on, then I will more readily suppress any
cancer that's growing. If I do have defects on my tumor suppressor genes, and then the ones that
are functioning are turned on, I will readily suppress the tumor that's growing, but less than if I
didn't have any defects on that gene. So there's multiple other factors. We cannot just look at my
tumor suppressor genes. We have to look at, are they methylated or not methylated? That's what the
IVG tests. So the IVG test is not looking at do I have defects? It's are the ones that I have turned
on or turned off, and are the other genes turned on or turned off, and that percentage is putting it
to the factor that gives us our IVG score. So like any other blood test out there, any other CT scan,
any other MRI, it's not going to be perfect, but it does give us a measurement that we could read out
where our cancer's at.